it's this huge robot that just goes
along rails
and takes pictures of plants i call it
the plant robot and inevitably the next
question that they always ask
is why why do you take pictures of
plants
arizona is described by some as having
the climate of tomorrow
today if we think about corn if you want
to see how it responds to drought
you need to bring it to an area like
this you know they don't build
volkswagens in maricopa arizona but they
bring them here to tess because
it is so extreme the crops growing here
can do so in upwards of 115 degree heat
often with limited water so as the
world's climate changes
how will farmers grow the crops of the
future
these scientists want to figure that out
thinking about the future
we need to start planning for it now
because if we don't we're going to
arrive at a situation in 50 years where
we're not equipped
to deal with it basically it'll change
the way we live
[Music]
does it get harder to like fill them up
i'm assuming when they go deeper in
at that point according to researchers
this is the largest agricultural robot
in the world
it's collecting data from crops here in
maricopa as part of a collaborative
effort between research institutions
to better understand plant genetics and
plant responses to the environment
a team of scientists and engineers from
the university of arizona
manage the day-to-day operations of the
field scanalyzer
and help process the data it collects
the project has been running since 2016
with funding from the department of
energy and the bill and melinda gates
foundation
the project aims to help produce
stress-resilient crops
ones that could thrive in warmer and
drier climates or help produce biofuels
to reduce reliance on fossil fuels
specifically like these ones you know
we're getting some extensive feeding
damage
the climate models predict that you know
100 years surface temperature will be
increased by five
five degrees centigrade that's a lot
different than what we have now
and we aren't going to be able to
develop plants fast enough to meet that
change in the environment
scientists are still trying to figure
out how likely that is
but paulie and his team are hoping to
produce plants that can withstand the
warmer temperatures forecast by several
climate models
the long-term goal is understanding you
know how we're going to address this
problem
of understanding drought resiliency
[Music]
you'll notice it has this large bank of
led lights how this camera operates
is it basically sends out a saturating
pulse of light that quenches all the
photo systems within the plant
and then we take a series of about a
hundred images in about two seconds
the 30 ton scanner referred to by the
team as the gantry
uses sensors and cameras to capture
detailed images of the width
length shape and angle of individual
plant leaves
a single scan can generate more than
fifteen thousand individual photos
the information we can gain from the
gantries we can try to see like which
which of these you know varieties behind
me is most efficient with sunlight
which one's best at taking that like you
know natural energy and converting it
into biomass
that's what we really want we want to
identify those plants that can do that
with the least amount of water possible
and so
those are the types of like
transformative insights that we're
really looking for
in terms of addressing some of these
larger problems poorly hopes that the
data collected from the gantry will be
transferable
not just to other crops but to other
localities
the technology driving this project is
really not anything special but it's
more about like the integration of
all these various different components
what i hope it will enable
sustainable farming sustainable
production of nutritious calories for
people
i mean that's the that's the goal of
this whole project is you know improving
the human condition
another crucial part of the project
happens two hours away in tucson
eric lyons leads a team of students who
grapple with the thousands of images
that come off the gantry on a daily
basis
creating up to 10 terabytes of data per
day once we have those coordinates we
can then go
back to our 3d images and say okay i
want a crop of this specific
area and that's what you're seeing here
one of the key challenges especially
with data coming off the gantry system
is we're dealing with sensor data from
about
half a dozen different cameras as well
as a bunch of environmental sensors
so we take all of these data in all
coming from different cameras
all requiring different kinds of data
processing
part of that processing involves machine
learning lions team is dealing with
thousands of images on a daily basis
machine learning algorithms help them
stitch these photos together
as well as identify individual plants
and track their progress over time
ideally we'd love to have predictive
models
often these are going to be based on
machine learning methods in order to say
before we plant a plant how is this
going to perform
given some scenario over its growing
season
how will it perform in a storm how will
perform in
a drought how it perform with excessive
heat days
how it will perform if it's particularly
cold and damp
while algorithms are making the job of
processing this data easier
the project still requires a human touch
that was the case
emanuel gonzalez is a grad student at
the university of arizona
he splits his time between the
computational side of the project in
tucson
and working with the crops in maricopa
it's really
important to have an exposure to both
there's the whole computational aspect
but there's also spending time with the
plants there's a sense of
other information that you get just from
being here the smaller details such as
you know how close are the plants
you know how do they feel my hope is
that
as a breeder in the future i can collect
data
that can inform growers into growing
their crops
more sustainably and what that would
hopefully translate into
is also making this technology available
widespread
not just to farmers here in the united
states but also
uh casting a wider net right throughout
the world
you know my family grew up in mexico
right and we have very similar weather
i don't really like to focus in on one
thing i always like to see things from a
global
perspective so this is 30 days out from
flowering
so basically right now our biggest risk
is like ensuring that we get
the plants actually flower and so any
type of this type of damage
just begins to like accumulate it's
still early days
but the team here hope that this data
could help the farmers of the future
grow successful crops in what could be
increasingly challenging conditions
if we do our job well the gantry will be
obsolete
and i say that not from like uh anything
jada it's just the fact that that means
that we've been able to take the
technology the inf like the
instrumentation
we've been able to like make it small
democratization basically
how do we take like some of the cameras
on board make them small
and put them in the pockets of you know
subsistence farmers or any farmer really
to basically improve crop production i
think in the future
farmers are going to rely increasingly
more
on technology i mean at the moment they
already do
there are sensors that they mount on
tractors and
they have subscriptions to a variety of
different geospatial technology out
there
and that's just going to increase i
think the farmer of the future is going
to
not only be able to know how to manage a
field and work the plant
but also be able to wrangle the
technology
and be able to make informed decisions
from that
[Music]
you